JOHN HOLL: That I have this
really-- like, the coolest job
on the planet.
And invariably there's
somebody in the crowd who's
saying, "Can I have your job?"
I imagine working for
a company like Google,
you guys are probably edging
me out on the coolness factor.
So thank you for all
that you guys do.
Technology has played a big part
in the evolving world of beer
these days.
Everything from
apps that allow you
to check into beer, to
websites that review beer,
to really just keeping breweries
in touch with consumers
these days.
And technology, I
think, has really
spread the good
word of good beer,
not only throughout the US, but
throughout the world as well.
I just came in from New
Zealand this afternoon.
I was on an overnight flight.
And their beer scene down
there is growing quite a bit.
And it was amazing
to me how many people
kept saying, "Well I was
reading on the internet
about this particular brewery.
Have you been there yet?"
There's a lot of enthusiasm.
So technology and beer
are both very social.
So cheers to what you guys do,
and thanks for having me here.
We have beer on the table.
So we're going to
do a beer tasting.
I'm going to talk about
the history of the beer.
I don't know why the
beers aren't open
and you guys aren't
already drinking,
but let's do that
first, if we can.
And I'm going to
steal from somebody.
As we do it.
Oh, I'm sorry.
We're going to
start with the can.
We're going to start with
Maui Brewing Company--
the beer in the can
that's in front of you.
That's probably helpful to
know, as opposed to all of you
guys going around and-- Hey.
Thank you guys.
So it's very important
to know that we
do have a limited amount
of beer for everybody.
So share and share alike.
Be Googly in your sharingness.
Right?
Is that a thing?
That's perfect.
About that much or
a little bit less
for each of the
beers in your glass.
And this is important for a
couple of different reasons.
One, we want the aroma to build
in these particular glasses.
Who's been to a
wine tasting before?
beer tasting before?
OK.
Who has not been to a
beer tasting before?
OK.
So those of you who
have not been to a beer
tasting before, you're
in for a lot of fun.
Those of you who've done it
before, you already know.
You'll notice right
off the bat that there
are no dump buckets
on the table.
That is because you are
supposed to drink the beer.
And you're supposed
to enjoy the beer.
If you don't like it,
give it your neighbor
and they'll finish
it off so that you
can fill up the next one.
Tasting beer is really one
of the most important things
about experiencing
the beer overall.
So let's just do
a quick tutorial
on how that works overall.
So the first thing you want
to look at is the appearance.
And if you have a little bit of
haze on the outside, that's OK.
So you want to see what the
color of the beer looks like.
And what does it
make you think of?
What does the straw golden
yellow liquid in front of you
make you think of?
And if you give it a
little bit of a swirl,
you can see the carbonation.
You can see that nice fluffy
white head appear on top.
Beer is wonderful to look
at a lot of the time.
But it's more fun to taste.
But before we get
to that, we're now
going to do the aroma of beer.
So there's two ways
of smelling a beer.
You can do the bloodhound,
where you get your nose in.
And you do a couple
quick sniffs.
And then you can do the
drive-by-- which I know in LA
means something
totally different.
And while you're
doing that, so much
of what we taste--
90% about-- is aroma.
It's aroma-driven.
So what we perceive as taste
is really aroma-driven.
So while you're smelling your
beer, think about food terms.
We're going to talk about
that in a little bit.
But think about what it
is that you're smelling.
Is it sweet grain?
Is it corn?
Is it floral?
Think about the
beer in food terms
as you go along with this.
And then obviously the next
thing to do is to taste.
Take whatever kind of sip
you're comfortable with.
And then you can
take a smaller one.
Really kind of see if the
aromas that you experience
with the beer-- and we're
going to have a range of beers
as we go through this today--
see if what you're smelling
matches what's on
your taste bud.
See how different tastes,
acidity, astringency,
sweetness, how all that
appears on your palate
once you've actually
tasted the beer.
And really think
about those flavors.
Then the next thing
is mouth feel.
And wine people
know that mouth feel
is very important with wine.
It's certainly very
important with beer.
So take a sip, just
a small enough sip
to float your
tongue, essentially.
And fell the carbonation
on your tongue.
Is it robust carbonation?
Is it super fizzy?
Is it light?
Is it a little bit more mellow?
And then think about how
it coats your tongue.
Is it watery?
Is it thick?
Is it falling somewhere
in the middle?
As we go on with some of
these-- and this particular beer
has a little bit of body to it.
It's got a little bit more oompf
than some of those other lagers
that you might see out there.
And for the color, it's got
a little bit more body to it.
This is the Maui Bikini Blonde.
This comes from Maui in Hawaii.
It's a Helles Lager.
And I have to go to
my cheat sheet here.
It's 5.1% alcohol.
And this to me is
what an American lager
should be these days, in the
promise that it can have.
It's got these really nice
bready characteristics to it.
It's got a little bit of
that floralness to it.
It's even got a little bit of a
lemony characteristic in there
as well.
I wish I could get this beer
in Jersey, where I live.
But my wife and I spent
a week in Maui last year,
and I drank this by the case.
And it was just-- it's a really,
really nice refreshing beer.
And we're going to
talk a little bit
about the history
of beer in America.
And it's interesting
to see that this
is where we're at with
beer these days-- that we
do once again have these rich,
full, flavorful lagers that
dominate-- or that are
beginning to come back
into the landscape.
We were a country
founded by beer.
The Mayflower landed
at Plymouth Rock
because, according to
the captain's diaries,
their provisions were running
low-- especially their beer.
They were drinking
beer on the way over.
It was running low.
And so they stopped
at Plymouth Rock
when they actually meant
to go down to Virginia.
And so from the
very start, what we
think of like the
birth of this country,
beer has played
an important role.
The founding fathers-- all
of their various farms,
and plantations, and
estates, all brewed beer.
A lot of people say that the
founding fathers brewed beer
themselves.
Maybe.
But chances are, they had the
women of the house doing it.
Or they had somebody
else doing it.
They were off doing other stuff.
And typically the men
in the house in that era
were not necessarily
the brewers themselves.
Over time, as we became
a country of immigrants,
more people came
over in 1700s, 1800s.
We were getting a lot of
people from UK, and Germany,
and other parts of
the world that already
had these established brewing
countries that had been around
for hundreds of years.
And as they set up in the
new cities on the East Coast,
and then slowly moved
west, these people
who had been brewers back
in their own home countries
started opening
up breweries here.
And so we were seeing
flavorful lagers.
We were seeing many
thousands of breweries
operating around the country.
And they were bringing their
home brewing traditions
to the US shores, using
what they could here.
This is where corn and
rice as added sweeteners
and fermentable sugars
came into play in brewing,
because that's just
simply what was available.
We saw more local
breweries back then.
We didn't have
refrigeration necessarily.
And the brewers didn't have
the means to make a lot of beer
to ship it across the country.
So if you lived
in New York City,
you went to your brewery
that was down in the Bowery.
Or you went to your brewery that
was on the upper parts of town,
or Brooklyn, or--
you drank local.
And that's something that
our country lost for a while,
because Prohibition came
into being, as it were.
And Prohibition was called
the noble experiment.
It failed.
From 1920 to 1933, the
country was relatively dry.
And during that time
a lot of the breweries
that were operating closed.
Which was really devastating
to these smaller breweries.
When we came out on the other
side, we emerged into a world
where larger breweries
thrived, got bigger, started
to expand their
distribution network,
and eventually became
the dominant players
throughout the country.
Smaller ones died off.
And so by the 1970s we were left
with not a great beer culture.
Only less than 100
breweries where we once
had many thousands of
breweries in this country.
So we've sort of had
this very strange history
with beer in the US.
And as people are
emptying their glasses,
we can start to open up the
Kellerweis from Sierra Nevada.
Don't be shy about doing that.
I'm going to-- this is going
to do wonders for my jet lag.
Oh yeah.
It's OK.
If we had a little bit of
water, we can suss it out,
but I'm going to steal a
little bit from you as well.
Thanks.
And that's just a really
quick, brief history
of beer in the US.
I mean there's obviously been
books and books and books
written about this,
but since we're here
to taste and talk
about food, that's
just sort of your quick one two.
In the late 1970s when the
brewing culture had really
been decimated, we
got to this point
where it could have
gone one of two ways.
And fortunately, it
went the good way.
And it started with a
guy named Jack McAuliffe.
In Sonoma in the late 1970s,
a former Naval engineer
who started home brewing
back when he was in the Navy
and stationed overseas, decided
to fabricate some equipment out
of some old stainless
dairy tanks, and opened up
and got a license for
a brewery in Sonoma.
And he called it New Albion,
and it made only a few barrels
of beer at a time, compared with
tens of millions being produced
by the larger
players on the scene.
By most accounts the
beer needed some work.
But the important thing
was that it was different.
And it was small.
And it gave people
an opportunity
to realize that beer
didn't have to just come
from many different
factories with the same label
throughout the country.
And so Jack up in Sonoma started
getting a lot of attention.
He got a spread the
"New York Times."
He got a spread in the
"Washington Post.""
People started coming
from around the country
to see what he was doing.
University of California
up in Berkeley,
which already had a professional
brewing school-- where
most of the students
who went through that
were destined for careers
at Anheuser-Busch,
or Miller Brewing Company,
or Coors Brewing Company,
started taking field
trips to Jack's place
and see that you could
fabricate small equipment
and make flavorful ales and
lagers on your own terms,
and not just follow what had
become mass-produced beer.
One of the people
who came and visited
owned a home brew supply shop
and a bicycle repair shop
in Chico, California.
And he came down and he
saw what Jack was doing.
And this guy had a
particular engineering mind,
and looked around and
said, "I could do this."
And so the guy's
name is Ken Grossman.
And he went back up to Chico.
And then he co-founded the
Sierra Nevada Brewing Company,
which is what we're
drinking right now.
We're drinking their Kellerweis,
which is a German-style wheat
beer that is-- going to my cheat
sheet again-- 4.8% alcohol.
It is brewed with wheat
along with malted barley,
so you're going to get a little
bit of that lemony flavor,
a little bit of
that tart flavor.
And then as you
swirl it around, he
uses this really
distinctive yeast
that gives off a particular
flavor and a particular aroma.
Is anybody picking up on
what the dominant aroma is?
Getting some citrus.
[INAUDIBLE] yup.
Banana.
That's it.
And now that we've said
that, is everybody else
picking up the banana now?
Yeah.
Beer is very suggestive.
I could have said, "Oh yeah.
Chocolate-covered cherries."
And people would
say, "Oh yeah, No.
I can get that as well."
I love screwing around
with people like that.
I like you guys too much,
so I'm not going to do that.
Yet.
But yeah, banana.
A little bit of clove
in there as well.
It's a really nice,
refreshing beer.
And Sierra Nevada is now the
second largest craft brewery
in America.
They just celebrated 34 years.
They're almost 35 now.
And they're producing just
about a million barrels
of beer a year.
They're going to grow
in the years to come.
Jack McAuliffe started with
about seven barrels of beer
a year.
If memory serves,
in the five years
that he lasted, the
best year that he had,
he produced somewhere
around 400 barrels.
There's 31 1/2 gallons in the
barrel, just for scale of size.
So Jack did 400
and change barrels.
Sierra Nevada, which was
inspired by Jack McAuliffe,
is now doing well
over a million.
And they're going to continue
to grow with the new facility
as well.
So Jack only lasted five years.
And the historian Maureen
Ogle, who wrote a great book
about the history of beer,
called "Jack's Brewery:
The Most Successful Failed
Brewery in America."
Because he really did inspire so
much of what's going on today.
So if you still have
beer in your glass,
I always like to just
do a quick toast to Jack
to thank him for where
we are these days.
Does anybody have any
questions while we're just
getting started?
It's the yeast.
So we should talk about
that a little bit.
There's four main
ingredients in beer.
And it's water, it's malt,
it's hops, and it's yeast.
And each of those
particular beers
have their own food
flavors to them.
And that's really where the
beer industry is right now,
is thinking about beer as food.
Beer is food.
But it's so difficult
sometimes to get that message
across for some of the brewers
because they're talking about,
"Well this is malty,
or this is hoppy.
Or, you know, boy it's got these
great yeast esters to them.
And we're not necessarily
thinking about-- hey,
there's some seats
in the front, guys.
They're not necessarily thinking
about beer as food terms.
So that's one of the
things that is probably
important to talk about.
And then if you guys want
to start pouring the stout,
you're more than welcome to if
you've gotten to that point.
If you haven't,
don't feel rushed.
This is not a marathon.
This is a fun beer tasting.
This is social.
It happens every time.
But I'm terribly sorry, sir.
You're cut off.
Alright so.
Beer as food.
Four main ingredients of beer--
water, malt, hops, and yeast.
Each of those four
main ingredients
have their own food flavors
and components on their own.
And so it's kind of fun to
break it out a little bit.
So you have water, which
can have a mineral or sulfur
content to it.
There's malt.
And depending on how
the malt is kilned,
which means roasted,
essentially.
It starts off as very pale.
And it can have a biscuity, or
grape-nutty, or cereal grain
kind of taste to it.
And the more you kiln it
and the more you roast it,
the darker it gets, and the
more flavors it takes on.
So you toast it a little bit.
And then it takes
on notes of caramel.
And then you roast
it some more, and you
start to get chocolate
and coffee and toffee.
And then you can go
really deep with it,
and it can turn even like
acrid black, and ash, even.
You could smoke the malt so that
you get a smoky flavor from it
as well.
And you just actually just
put the kiln malt over a flame
with a smoke, and it
infuses those flavors.
And then when you brew it, it
takes on those flavors as well.
So sometimes you get
some heat-smoked malt,
and some other cherry
wood-smoked malts,
and all different
kind of smoked malts,
and it takes it
on there as well.
But these are all flavors
to think about with the malt
itself.
And I'm getting
distracted, because I
want to go grab
another beer if I can.
Thank you, sir.
You're a wonderful assistant.
I appreciate it.
Well it shows.
Your skills are impeccable.
So we'll talk about the
other two in a second.
But this is a very malt-forward
beer now that we're pouring.
This is the Oatis from Ninkasi.
And I looked this up
just a few minutes ago.
And this is about 7.2%.
They make this out
of Eugene, Oregon.
I love pairing this
in a beer float
with a scoop of
vanilla ice cream.
Or it goes well with a really
hardy lamb stew as well.
When you smell this and
you do that whole aroma
thing with the beer-- and I'll
try not to do that again--
what are some of the
flavors or aromas
that you're getting off of this?
Coffee, chocolate.
Those are the two big ones.
And then when you taste it, are
those flavors coming through
as well?
Yeah.
What's really interesting is
that there is neither coffee
nor chocolate in this beer.
It all comes from
the roasted malt.
They use a variety of
different malts in there,
including a malt that is
called chocolate malt.
And when you get some of
that, and you eat it raw,
it does taste like a
piece of bitter chocolate,
or it can, or various
types of chocolate.
So that's always kind of fun,
because people swear, "No!
There's definitely coffee
or chocolate in there."
There's not.
And that just shows just how
diverse malts can be depending
on how it's kilned
and how it's roasted.
This is a big kind of--
on the mouth feel of this,
it's very creamy.
It's very-- there's
oatmeal in this as well.
Flaked oats in
this beer as well.
So you're going to get a little
bit of that chewy, a little bit
of that creamy mouth
feel off of this.
People think about Guinness
as a big, dark, heavy beer.
Try the mouth feel trick next
time you're out with Guinness.
And you're going to notice that
it's actually fairly watery.
It doesn't have a
lot of body to it.
Its that nitrogen
pour off of the bar
that gives it a creamy
sort of texture.
But the beer itself
is very watery.
This is robust.
Sticks to your ribs.
Like I say, lamb stew or
one of those cold winter
nights that LA is famous for.
If I chilled this down, and
proper beer serving temperature
is usually in the cellar
temperature range, so
about 50 or so degrees.
But I admit that
sometimes in the summer
I will chill down one
of these to that ice
bucket-cold mountain stern
blue, kind of pull it out
of the cooler and drink
it ice cold on a hot day.
And it's super refreshing.
It's almost like
drinking an iced coffee.
Except it's got the
other kind of benefits
aside from caffeine.
So the next ingredient is hops.
And when people say to me,
"Oh, I don't like beer."
I ask them why.
And some people will say, "Oh,
I don't like the taste of it.
It's too bitter." "Or
it's just not for me."
And the bitterness
stands out because that's
what hops give beer.
Not only aroma, but they
also give bitterness.
And bitter is a terrible word.
Bitter is sort of like
when you have a kid brother
and you're eating something as
children that you don't like,
and you go, "Oh, this is awful.
Here, try this."
You immediately have
this connotation of like,
"I'm not going to enjoy
this," When you say bitter.
And so one of the things I like
to say with people-- and again
if people are ready to move
onto the next one, that's fine.
We can talk about it again.
Hops can have flavors
and aromas of everything
from citrus, like
tangerine and orange,
and lemon and lime
leaf, to tropical fruits
like pineapple, or
guava, or mango.
There's other hops that have
resin or pine aromas to them.
They're still new ones that
have peach or blueberry
aromas coming off of them.
And where I was in New Zealand
recently, they have their hops.
And they're breeding them
and they're growing them.
And they have these
aromas of gasoline.
You know when you pump gas, and
then you get back in the car,
and about 20 minutes later,
you kind of smell your hand.
It's that faint smell of petrol?
That's what's appearing
in these hops these days.
And they love it
for some reason.
And there's also like a smell of
what I was calling sweat socks,
and they were calling laundry.
And they're putting
this in their beer.
But again, when you know what
it is that you're smelling,
and you know that the brewers
want it in their intentionally,
it's not quite as unappealing
as it might sound.
So when we move on to
the next beer, which
is going to be the AleSmith
IPA, think about some
of those aromas that
I just talked about.
See if any of those present in
your mind as you're tasting it.
And then recognize
that at the end,
when you get a little
bit of that bite,
that pucker, that bitterness
on the end, that'll
be an "in the back of your
tongue" kind of thing,
think about the flavors
that you smell first.
And then suddenly
bitterness becomes a lot
more approachable in beer,
especially with IPAs,
which is a really
decisive thing for people.
It's the most entered
category-- the India pale ales--
in the Great American
Beer Festival every year.
It is the beer style that
is leading this craft beer
charge that we're in these days.
And unfortunately,
like I say, there
hasn't been great education
to the general public
on experiencing the overall
flavor notes of an IPA.
But if you think about it from
the pine notes, or the fruit
notes, or even the
gasoline notes,
you're going to come
around a little bit more
and hopefully enjoy
those overall flavors.
Yes.
Why do I think IPAs are
more popular in the craft--
because they're big, and
bold, and unapologetic,
and in your face,
and that is America.
[APPLAUSE]
It's interesting.
There's a couple of
different theories on this.
And I'm sort of of the mindset
of, for a long time in the US,
when we had these
generic lagers that
were out there-- that are
technically perfectly made--
they just don't
have a lot of flavor
that appeals to a lot of new
beer drinkers these days.
The IPAs is a run in
a different direction.
One, it's an ale, not a lager.
But two, it's just so jam-packed
with flavor, with extra booze,
it's just the polar opposite.
And that's what
the brewers wanted.
They wanted to say, "Yeah, you
all knew these guys over here.
This is us over here.
This is flavor country."
As it were.
And I think that's
one of the reasons
that it's led the charge.
Interestingly enough,
we are seeing a change
in the overall beer
market these days.
People are tending towards
sessionable beers, or more
well-balanced beers these
days, where you can actually
taste all four ingredients
in the beer, and not just
a dominant hop, which
is really quite great,
and it shows the overall
maturity of the market
right now.
But I think it was
really just running
in the opposite direction
of where we had been.
And where beer really took
off up in northern California,
and in Oregon and Washington.
They were already growing
hops up there to begin with,
and so hops became a fairly
dominant flavor in there.
People started
opening up the IPA.
What are some of the aromas
that you're getting off of that?
Orange.
Mango pine.
Grapefruit.
Freedom.
Smells like bald eagles
and monster truck rallies.
I'd love to get this at
a monster truck rally.
But when you taste it thought,
the malt characteristic really
comes through on this as well.
You get a little bit of
that biscuity, cereal grain,
little bit of caramelization
in there as well.
You'll also notice that when
you hold it on your tongue
and do mouth feel, it's
going to be a bit more chewy.
It's going to be
a bit more thick.
Again, people say, "Oh,
I don't like dark beers.
They're too heavy."
And they might tend
towards this because it's
this nice sort of like
burnt orange amber.
This is actually
heavier than a lot
of those commercial
stouts that are out there.
You can kind of feel that.
And you can also see that
as well with the lacing
on the glass.
And just how robust
this particular beer is.
So we talked about water.
We talked about malt.
We've talked about hops.
There's an old
saying that brewers
make wort-- which is a sweet
liquid, sugary liquid--
but yeast makes the beer.
And so when you add yeast to
sweet wort it eats the sugars
and creates alcohol
and CO2 carbonization.
And without yeast, we
would not have beer.
So be thankful for
that little micro.
The flavors of yeast,
which are so diverse,
can be everything
from-- and we've already
seen this-- from
banana and bubble gum.
There's pepper.
There is flowers.
There's honey.
There's bubblegum is a
great yeast flavor as well.
It's really quite
diverse, the various yeast
flavors out there.
And different styles of beer
use different styles of yeast.
So Belgian beers will have a
lot of very fruity ester yeast
that could have stone
fruits and plums
and really great depths
of a honey kind of thing.
And then you'll
have some others,
like we said, some of
these German beers that
could have banana or clove.
Or just can be very
crisp and clean as well,
where it does let the
other flavors come through.
The Kellerweis is
really the best example
of a yeast-forward beer that
we have up here right now.
And again, if you go onto
YouTube at some point,
Sierra Nevada does another beer.
And this is an open
fermented beer,
which essentially means that
they pour the sweet wort
into these large tanks which
look like bathtubs, that
are essentially the
size of this stage here.
And much, much taller.
And they fill it
with the sweet wort.
And they add the yeast to it.
And it open ferments, and then
it bubbles and blows over.
And it's a really
fun thing to watch.
Sierra Nevada has a video
where they do their Bigfoot
Barleywine every year in
the same open fermenters.
And if you YouTube
it or you Google it,
you can see this very
cool minute-long video
of just this yeast
kind of exploding off
of these open
bathtub fermenters.
Most of the beer is
done-- most normal beer.
Not normal-- that's
a terrible word.
These other beers are probably
done in closed fermentation
tanks where the yeast can
blow off if it needs to.
But if you're looking
for a fun visual,
that's a cool video to look up.
I probably should have
shown it, but that's
poor planning on my part.
Overall thoughts on the IPA?
I should say that
this is the AleSmith
IPA, down in San Diego.
7.25%.
With food, I would go with
spicy Thai would go really
well with this.
Blue cheese would go
really well with this.
And also carrot cake would go
exceptionally well with this.
And that kind of brings us
to how beer pairs with food.
So after Jack McAuliffe
came and left,
and the new breweries like
Sierra Nevada opened up,
we had a fun couple years of
what was called micro brew.
And it got a lot of attention.
It was these small brewers
that were doing various beers.
Unfortunately, not all of
them were doing a good job.
And what we found was that
they closed over time.
They had these beers that
were taking an animal name,
and they were taking a bodily
fluid, and mixing it together.
So you were getting like
beaver spit, or monkey piss,
or something terrible.
And people would go
and buy these six packs
and bring it to
parties as a joke.
They would be like, "Hey!
Look what I saw on the shelf.
Isn't this crazy?"
And your friends
would look at you
kind of like, you're a jackass.
And when you tasted the beer,
it tasted like, you know,
beaver sweat.
And so a lot of these
businesses went out of business.
And the ones that
survived grew and became
better at what they were doing.
They really focused on quality.
They really focused on flavor.
It wasn't just a fad for them.
This was a long term
business and an industry
that they wanted to grow
of these microbreweries.
The name was
essentially rebranded
to craft beer to
kind of get away
from the bad connotations
of micro brewing.
And once that
really took off, you
start to see it everywhere now,
which is a really great thing.
From Jack McAuliffe
being the first craft
brewer in the late 1970s, we
now have 3,000 plus breweries
operating in the country.
With another 1,000
planning to come online
within the next couple of years.
It's grown tremendously.
And all these-- or most
of them, I should say--
are really focused on
quality and they're
focused on their local area.
With so many people now
knowing about craft beer,
there's now an
attention being paid
to pairing good
beer with good food.
And that's where the
cookbook comes into play.
I spent 2 and 1/2 years working
on the "American Craft Beer
Cookbook."
Pulling recipes from
around the country,
from breweries that I know,
breweries that I respect,
beer bars that I
know and respect,
and even a few from
my own kitchen.
And what I really
wanted to do was
highlight the diversity of beer.
And so you hear a lot of
people say, "Oh, you know,
when it comes to alcoholic
beverages and food pairings,
red meat goes with red
wine, and white wine
goes with chicken and fish."
It's not that black and
white, as any real wine
lover will tell you.
It's certainly not easy to paint
a picture like that with beer.
So we've already talked
about the great diversity
with these flavors of these
beers that we've had so far.
And I'm going to just
ask you guys to hold off
on opening up that last one
before we go any further.
You can finish off some of
these others that we have.
Leave no man behind.
Leave no beer in the
bottles, as it were.
When it comes to
pairing beer with food,
we can't just think
about our protein.
Like that wine saying goes.
We really need to think about
how the food is prepared,
what it's being
served with, what's
being served on top of it.
So an example that I
like to use quite a bit
when it comes to thinking
about beer and food is a steak.
And so you go to a
nice steak house,
and invariably somebody's gonna
offer you a glass of red wine.
But why does red wine work?
And for a number of reasons.
It's a bold flavor that can
stand up to bold flavor.
For other reasons, it just
looks good on the plate,
in the glass, and on
the plate as well.
With beer, it's fun to
think about the steak
and how it's prepared.
And so you throw a
steak on the grill,
and you're going to
get that caramelization
of the fat, a little
bit of that black char
on the outside of it.
And then when you
cut into the steak,
you're going to get these
savory juices in there as well,
and that meatiness of the
overall piece of steak.
And if there's vegetarians
in the crowd, I'm sorry.
I'm going to stick
with this meat motif.
And so I think about a
brown ale, or a Porter,
or even a stout when
I start thinking
of a steak on the grill.
And that's because
of the malts that we
talked about before,
which have some
of those caramel notes to them.
Maybe a little
bit of that black,
acridness to it that will
complement those existing
flavors on the outside char
and outside crust of the steak.
And then when you
cut it open and you
get those savory juices,
the sweetness of the beer
is going to contrast
with the meat itself,
and bring out a whole new
dimensions of flavors as well.
But then you say, "Alright.
So a brown ale
goes with a steak."
But not always.
Because what happens
if you put a Gorgonzola
sauce, or a blue cheese
sauce on top of that steak?
Now that's really going to
become the dominant flavor.
And you're going
to need something
that could stand up to that.
And that's where
something like an IPA
comes in, because it can
stand up to those blue cheese
flavors, kind of cut
through some of that fat,
and really bring
out some roundedness
and some of those
other flavors as well.
So you can't just think
about your protein.
You have to think about
what it's served with,
what it's being served
alongside with as well.
And as you drink more beer, and
you think about beer as food,
with going through those flavors
that we talked about earlier,
it's going to become
easier and easier
to pair good beer
with good food.
The other thing that's
important to mention
is that it's not just the
four main ingredients in beer
these days, but brewers,
especially in the US,
are fearless-- and
sometimes foolhardy--
that they will brew with
just about anything.
So these days you'll actually
get chocolate in your beer,
and you'll get
coffee in your beer,
and you'll get tea in your beer.
And then you'll have
all sorts of manners
of exotic fruits in your beer.
Not just ones you find
at the grocery store,
but ones that they are traveling
to Africa to source, things
that a lot of us have never
heard of here in the States.
They're finding
vegetables to brew with.
There's one particular
brewer a couple of years
ago that brewed a beer
with grilled beef hearts.
It was not good.
You know when you walk
into a butcher shop
and you get that tinny, blood,
metallic scent in the air?
Yeah.
You would open up a
bottle over there,
and it would just kind
of waft around the room.
And it had a very short
shelf life, thankfully.
And I don't think they make it
anymore, which is quite good.
But it shows that
brewers are really
trying to bring different
things into beer.
I try to find beers that
are brewed with honey,
and I pair it with
ham a lot of the time.
Just the thought
being honey baked ham
is such a great combination,
that why can't it work?
To that point, on
the ham thing, there
are beers being
brewed with bacon
that are actually
really quite nice.
It's like a breakfast
beer in a lot of ways,
especially if they've added
some coffee in there as well.
So there's a lot going
on and the only thing
that limits brewers
these days is
their own imagination
and their own creativity.
So it's an awesome time to be
a beer drinker in the US right
now.
So I just challenge you to think
about that with beer and food
next time you're out.
Don't necessarily reach for a
glass of wine instinctively,
but really think about what it
is that you're going to eat.
And think about why you're
having a glass of wine
or a glass of beer
along with it,
and try to find something that
is as good in the glass that
is as good on your
plate, and see
if you can't meld them together.
And that's something
that's really important.
And I'm not anti-wine.
I just want to point that out.
A lot of people are like,
oh, you're against the grape.
I'm really not.
I drink a lot of wine.
I drink a lot of spirits.
I drink a lot.
You guys laugh.
Every time I do that joke,
my wife is rolling her eyes.
It's not true.
It's a little bit true.
The last thing that I'll mention
is cooking with beer as well.
As you're flipping
through the cookbook,
you'll see that a lot
of the recipes in there
use beer as an ingredient.
Not only is beer fun to pair
with, beer is fun to cook with.
And adding a beer to a dish is
like adding a spice cabinet.
Because once you degas the
beer, once you heat it up,
once you've added
garlic to anything,
it's not going to taste the
way that it does in our glass.
It's going to taste
totally different.
And so you're going to get
deeper flavors from it.
It could be like using a stock.
Beer is great in
salad dressings.
Its great as a marinade.
Not only does it add some
tenderness to the meat,
or to your protein, by having
the carbonation nibble away
at it a little bit,
but it also can
add some additional
sweetness that can bring out
some of the more
savory flavors as well.
Don't just cook with beer for
the sake of cooking with beer.
As I was researching
this book, there's
been a lot of your
cookbooks in the past,
and one thing that
I wanted to avoid
was people say, well,
add a tablespoon of lager
and then move on.
That does nothing
to the overall--
if you're going to cook
with beer, cook with beer.
One of the recipes in there
uses an entire six pack
of a scotch ale in there.
Which I know, people
are like, well,
why would you use
an entire six pack?
Because it's good when it
comes out on the other end.
And that's why.
Because anything less than
six or anything more than six
just wouldn't have done.
So cooking with beer
can be a lot of fun,
but not if you're just going to
do it for the sake of doing it.
The cookbook itself--
as you can see--
has 155, it's
actually 157, but that
didn't have the same
ring for the cover.
Breakfast to dessert.
People say, why breakfast?
I say, Frank Sinatra
used to say you
can't drink all day unless
you start in the morning.
There are a lot of
vegetarian options.
I know I spent a lot of time
talking about meat today.
But there are vegetarian and
gluten-free options in there.
I think that's important.
We've moved beyond the
days of burger and bud,
and pork nachos and beer,
and all sorts of things.
There's a lot of
great diversity that
comes with food these days.
And there's a lot
of great diversity
that comes with beer these days.
And really quickly,
I'll just say
that it's been fun
to watch the way
that the two worlds--
the food world
and the beer world have evolved
together in the last few years.
So we talked about prohibition,
and after prohibition how we
all kind of became these
generic-- oh, yeah,
I'll-- these generic beers that
were out there, these lagers.
Our food culture kind of
went the same way as well.
Our grandparents, our
great grandparents,
they all knew where dinner
came from every night.
And so you'd have fresh
baked bread on the table.
Your meat came from
the local butcher.
Your vegetables came
from the green grocer
or from the backyard.
And you knew what
it was that you
were putting into your body.
But slowly over
time, that changed
and we became this culture of
convenience and mass-produced.
And so real cheese
became Velveeta.
And fresh-baked bread
became Wonder Bread.
And rather than
working on a dinner,
even if it would only take an
hour at the end of the night,
we convinced ourselves
that we were so busy
that we pop a plastic
tray into the microwave,
and whatever came out
two minutes later,
we'd call that dinner.
We've moved on.
I mean we still have a lot
of that in the country,
but we're starting to see
more and more that people care
about where their
food is coming from.
They want to know
who's making their food
The localvore movement
is coming back into play.
Farmers' markets haven't
been this popular in ages.
People really care
about what they're
putting in their bodies.
And the same thing is true
for the brewing industry.
You can walk into your
local brewers around here--
and you guys have quite a
few here in the LA area,
and more and more it
seems all the time--
and you can meet the
people who make your beer.
You can shake the hand
of the guy or woman who
made what is now in your glass.
And that's a personal
connection, as well.
It's like knowing where
your vegetables came from.
And so to see the
craft beer movement
and the localvore movement
kind of come together
has really been great for
the beer and food movement,
and books like this.
So that's just another
thing to think about.
When you're buying
craft beer, you're
supporting smaller businesses,
you're supporting local,
and you're doing your part
to do right by yourself
by getting some good, flavorful
beer into your system.
There's a question over here.
AUDIENCE: In regards
to cooking, how
do the four different
ingredients-- probably
mostly the hops and the
yeast, those flavors--
how do they stand up to
cooking, and what do you lose?
JOHN HOLL: So the question
is, how does the four
main ingredients stand up
when you're cooking with beer?
It really depends on the beer.
I tend to find that more
malt-forward beers work
a little bit better than
more hop-forward beers
when it comes to cooking.
The hops can take on some
astringency and some not nice
flavors, if you're going to
be boiling it for a long time.
Whereas more
malt-forward beers, I
think go a lot further, just
because of the sweetness
that it brings to the game.
But it really depends
on the overall beer
that you're cooking with.
I try to be as specific
as possible in the book,
and saying like, if you're
going to cook with this beer,
here's why you
should, and here's
some of the flavors
that come out with it.
And it was a lot of
fun trial and error
to try to come up with that
while I was doing that.
So we can get into the general
question portion of things now.
And with that, opening
up the last beer.
So IPAs have been leading the
charge in the US for a while.
And I keep hearing from
people, oh, a sours
going to be the next IPA.
I don't know if
they are, but this
is going to be a Sour Blonde
from the Almanac Brewery
Company up in the
San Francisco area.
It's tart.
It is brewed with two types
of cherry-- a Rainier cherry
and I'm so hesitant
to use this, the name
of the variety of cherry
that they use here.
It's called Bing.
I was reading the description
before, and I was like, oh,
man.
I'm bringing like
a Bing to Google.
That's so weird.
And this has been aged
in wine barrels as well.
There's a lot going
on with this beer.
It's 7%.
Uses three types
of yeast in here,
including famous San
Francisco sourdough yeast
culture in there.
So as you're doing your
aromas and your flavors
and everything in
between, you're
going to get a lot of things.
I'm going to come down
and join you if I may.
Thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN HOLL: What's that?
JOHN HOLL: Right.
Are there Google cherries?
If not.
Get on it.
So that's kind of where we're
at it very quickly with beer
and food these days,
in the history of beer
and how we got to sitting
in a room drinking
a wide range of diverse beers
from a wide range of mostly
West Coast breweries.
And any thoughts?
Any questions?
I'll go back there, and yes.
AUDIENCE: If possible, can
you use the microphone?
Just for the sake
of the YouTube?
JOHN HOLL: Yes.
This is going on the YouTube.
So if you could
use the microphone.
AUDIENCE: So you talked about
these wonderful food pairings.
I mean, some of us
were getting actively
hungry in the back there.
I'm wondering, in addition
to these speaking tours,
if you considered doing sort
of an event where we come in,
and we try some of the beer,
some of the food together.
Do you spiel on the steak.
Now with the
Gorgonzola, now without.
JOHN HOLL: Yes.
How soon do you want me
to come back and do that?
AUDIENCE: Um, Saturday?
JOHN HOLL: Sure.
AUDIENCE: That'd be good for me.
JOHN HOLL: Absolutely.
I will absolutely.
Yeah, I do that quite a bit.
We do beer dinners
and beer tastings.
And that's a fun thing.
Scan-- and I love
doing it, but they're
happening all over the
country these days.
Sign up when you go and
visit your local brewery,
and sign up for
their newsletters.
And they will send you different
things that they're doing.
And you'll really find beer
dinners that they're doing
and beer and cheese
pairings that they're doing.
Boy, you're really
having a tough time
with this microphone, man.
AUDIENCE: I am.
Yes.
JOHN HOLL: You are
cut off at this point.
You're now the second
person to get cut off.
The cool thing, and
one of the things
I didn't really touch about with
this book, is beer is local,
but so is food.
And so when you look
through this book,
you're going to find
seafood dishes that
come from New England and
the Pacific Northwest.
And you're going to
find spicy dishes that
come from the southwest.
And you're going to
find meat and dairy
dishes that come
from the heartland.
Or you're going to find very
city-specific food traditions
as well.
And the book kind of
overall tells the story
of where we are with beer and
food, and how both can be local
and how both can play
with local strength.
So I love doing beer dinners.
And especially when
I travel around,
because I get to talk with chefs
and brewers and be like, OK.
Here in LA, there's a great
food truck culture that exists.
And there's a really
great Mexican that exists.
Let's find these
local food traditions
and find local beers that bring
out the best flavors in both.
And that's really
the cool thing.
So the point that I
was trying to make
is find your local brewers,
find good local beer bars around
here, and see if they're
doing beer dinners.
And go and just sit and taste.
It's a lot of fun to do.
And it's fun to get out
with friends as well.
And it's something
different to do as well.
Awesome date nights.
It's all sorts of very cool--
there's very cool stuff
that's happening.
But, yeah.
Any time you guys want me to
come back and do a beer dinner,
yeah.
I'm on the next
plane from Jersey.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN HOLL: Yes.
Yes sir.
First times the charm.
I like that.
AUDIENCE: I am mic enabled.
Yes.
So you were mentioning
the pairing with a steak.
You mentioned you
have some blue cheese,
you add either a Porter
or perhaps a stout.
What is the modern
difference between those?
JOHN HOLL: God, I
hate that question.
AUDIENCE: I know.
JOHN HOLL: Very little.
AUDIENCE: That's what I thought.
AUDIENCE: I was always
just kind of assuming--
JOHN HOLL: Yeah.
It's evolved over time.
When you look at the overall
definitions when judging
is done.
It can be tough to tell the
difference between the two.
AUDIENCE: There's even
different categories.
JOHN HOLL: Exactly.
It's different categories.
I Some people make the argument
that it's Irish versus United
Kingdom kind of difference.
Guinness versus London
Porter kind of thing.
Yeah.
There's not-- there's not a
heck of a lot of difference,
on its face, of them.
When you start getting into
some of the larger, or the more
boozy, complex,
stouts and porters,
the differences
become more vast.
The difference between a foreign
Extra Stout and a Baltic Porter
are a little bit different.
Yeah I hate that question,
because I get it all the time.
And I've never come up
with a really good answer
that people walk away
feeling, you're a genius!
So, Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So, much easier
personal preference question.
Obviously you get asked every
day, what's your favorite beer?
But within your
favorite style-- if you
have one-- what is your favorite
beer that you've ever tasted?
JOHN HOLL: Favorite beer
that I've ever tasted.
Shit.
That's a tough question.
AUDIENCE: Assuming
you don't have
a favorite that
you've never tasted.
JOHN HOLL: Right.
There are known knowns.
And there are known unknowns,
and unknown unknowns.
I tend toward stouts
and porters myself.
It's really sort of my
go to style if I'm out.
But it really depends
on where I'm at,
who I'm with, what's
local, what tastes good.
For the purposes of when I
do beer tastings at home,
and judging, I keep Sam
Adams Foster and a Lager,
and Sierra Nevada
Pale Ale in my fridge.
And that's because I know
exactly how those beers
taste like.
They're not my go to's, but
I'm very familiar with them,
and that helps when
I'm tasting new beers.
Because if I feel like I'm
tasting something that's
an off flavor, or I'm
feeling like I'm just
having a bad tasting day,
I can open up one of those.
And if it tastes how I know
it's supposed to taste,
then I know that there's
something wrong with this beer
that I'm tasting.
If those beers don't
taste right to me,
it means that I had
something weird for lunch.
And it's throwing
me off a little bit.
There's a couple of beers
throughout the country,
and I hate playing favorites,
because I run this beer
magazine where we're
impartial, but there's
a couple of beers that
I do try to seek out
whenever I'm traveling.
New Glarus out in
Wisconsin makes
a beer called Raspberry Tart
which is just phenomenal.
It's about 4% alcohol, made
with fresh raspberries.
It's like a brown
ale with raspberries.
It's just delightful.
The Cambridge Brewing
Company out in Massachusetts
does a Summer
Barleywine that they
call arquebus that's
about 14% alcohol, that's
got these really wonderful
boozy vanilla flavors.
And they only put
it out once a year.
And it seems like I'm on a
train from New York up to Boston
every summer just to taste
this particular beer.
But for me these
days, there are so
many cool beers to
be tasted out there,
that I haven't found
my next favorite yet.
And I haven't found
the next one that's
going to stop me dead in my
tracks and make me say, wow.
And that's kind
of a cool thing is
it just shows how much
the brewers are pushing
the envelope these days, and
really continually trying
to make themselves better.
It's always a lot
of fun when I smell
a beer for the first time,
like I did with this one.
And I get this big
smile on my face,
because I know as
soon as I smell it
that I'm really going
to enjoy this beer.
And that's a cool thing because
that still happens quite a bit.
And you'd think with 3,000
breweries in the country
that it wouldn't
happen quite so much.
But it is.
I'm really digging the cherries
off of this by the way.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned beef hearts.
JOHN HOLL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So ignoring that.
What's your favorite gimmick
ingredient and your least
favorite gimmick ingredient
that you've tried thus far.
JOHN HOLL: Beef hearts
is my least favorite.
AUDIENCE: Besides beef hearts.
JOHN HOLL: Besides beef hearts.
Probably my favorite is coffee.
I think coffee just
brings so much to stouts.
And there's brewers that
are trying different things
these days with coffee.
We have a brewery
in New Jersey called
Carton which did a
coffee light and sweet.
So that's sort of
an East Coast thing.
I don't know if it's out
here, but it's basically
like three sugars and
milk in your coffee.
And so it's like coffee
for kids, essentially.
And they did a
beer that was maybe
about this color, thereabouts.
But it had a good
ton of coffee in it.
And when you think
of a coffee beer,
you're not necessarily thinking
of a light colored beer
as well.
And so I really dig
that, because they
use some lactose sugar,
which is milk sugar,
and the coffee in
it, so it actually
tasted like a coffee light and
sweet, which was kind of fun.
Coffee's also great with IPAs.
Stone Brewing Company
a couple years ago
did a collaboration--
Dayman Coffee,
where it was these
bright floral hoppy
notes with this really
nice kick of coffee.
And again, lighter color.
My magazine did a collaboration
with Sierra Nevada Brewing
a couple months
ago, where we also
did a coffee IPA with
Counterculture Coffee, which
is a growing chain
and growing business.
And we tried different
coffee varieties
where we wanted ones that had
berry and lemon notes to it.
Then we found hops to match,
so that it brought out
those additional flavors.
So I'm really digging
what's happening
with coffee these days.
As I've been rambling
on that, I've
been really trying to think
about some of the bad stuff
that I've had.
There's a lot of
brewers that are
using rare and exotic
fruits these days.
And sometimes it works,
and sometimes it doesn't.
The thing that I'm hesitant to
say about things that I overly
don't like is that I might
not like it, but you might.
And then who am I to say
that this is not a good beer?
And who are any of us to say
that it's not a good beer?
If somebody likes
the taste of it,
that's a personal preference.
I'm sure as we did this
tasting today that you noticed
that some of you
really liked it.
Maybe your neighbor sitting
next to you is like, oh
that's not for me.
I saw people passing
off their glasses.
And there's no shame in that.
Beer is a very
personal experience.
Brewers are trying
weird stuff these days.
But it's from the weird
stuff that you sometimes
get the best stuff.
And it's that continually
pushing of the innovation.
It's that continually pushing
of brewers going and finding
weird ingredients.
Oyster stouts have been
around for a really long time.
And oysters and stouts are
a wonderful beer and food
pairing.
And so putting oysters
into your stout
really brings out the
sort of like savoriness
in the beer along with
some of that sweetness,
and adds a little bit
of body and depth to it.
I love oyster stouts.
But if there's
people here who are
squeamish at the
idea of oysters,
or eating raw shellfish,
you're not going to like that.
And so it's tough
to say ingredients
that I don't personally like.
There's some people who
are tea drinkers and not
coffee drinkers who
are just turned off
by my whole little
spiel on coffee.
So it's a tough thing to
really say these days.
It's judge each beer yourself.
And if you like it,
drink more of it.
If you don't, you're
going to find something
that you will like.
Questions?
You guys can duke it out there.
Is there any of
more this Almanac?
Somewhere?
Sorry, I just need to reload.
I'm not joking.
I got off of a plane like three
hours ago from New Zealand.
I've been up for like 24 hours.
And I still have to fly
back to Jersey tonight.
So this is-- my seat mate is
going to hate me on the plane.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah
I'd love to hear--
kind of a two-part question.
First question is how your
opinion of California breweries
versus breweries
from other states.
And then part two
are what are three
beers we have to
try before we die?
JOHN HOLL: Good questions.
California has
the most breweries
out of any state in
the Union right now.
So by nature of that, you have
a really big, diverse beer
culture.
San Diego is a hop
capital right now.
They're doing these
really big, dank,
super hoppy, super
aggressive beers.
And you're seeing some of those
in other parts of the state
as well.
Hops come into big
play in California.
Whereas other states use them,
but maybe not in the same way
that California does.
If you say to somebody a San
Diego, or a West Coast style
IPA, chances are
that they're thinking
of California,
specifically San Diego.
But then you go up to
Berkeley and San Francisco
and that general area,
where this beer comes from,
and they're doing a lot of
barrel aging, because they're
in wine country, or
close to wine country.
And there's access to barrels.
And they're really
interested in those flavors.
And they're
interested in using--
like with this beer--
that wild sourdough
to help culture the beer.
So it's a really
diverse beer state.
I mean, it's a great
beer state, no doubt.
Three beers that
you have to try.
That's a really tough one.
Because when you talk about--
is it the global beer scene.
Is it the US beer scene?
Is it your local beer scene?
I think that there's
a couple of beers
that have shaped
the US right now.
Sierra Nevada Pale Ale, I
think everybody should taste.
I think that's a great beer.
That it has a great hop
characteristic to it.
But it also has a great
malt characteristic to it.
It's a very, very
well-balanced beer.
It's a very easy drinking beer.
And it's found
everywhere these days.
And it can be easy to forget
that when it first came out,
that it was revolutionary
in a lot of ways.
So many-- if Ken Grossman was
inspired by Jack McAuliffe,
whole new generations of
brewers were originally
inspired by Sierra Nevada
and that particular beer.
So that's a fun beer
to pay attention to.
Man, I'm really
trying to think of--
I already mentioned
Raspberry Tart
from New Glarus, which is
for me, one of those ones
that everybody should try.
And they have an
interesting business model
that they're doing more than
100,000 barrels of bee a year,
and they're just staying
in the state of Wisconsin.
They're choosing to stay
local, which is incredible
when you think about
how people are shipping
their beer around the
country and around the world.
Will Myers makes that awesome
arquebus from Cambridge,
but you can only
get it if you're
at his pub in Cambridge,
Massachusetts.
So that's a tough thing to say.
AUDIENCE: We have an
office in Cambridge.
JOHN HOLL: You do have
an office in Cambridge?
Road trip.
Let's go!
Next summer we're all gonna
meet at Cambridge Brewing
and we're all gonna
drink the arquebus.
Yeah, I mean those kind
of jump out in my mind.
But again, I've had
so many good beers.
I've had these wonderful
bourbon barrel aged beers.
Full Sail Brewing Company
does a bourbon barrel aged
imperial stout every year that
has these really wonderful
boozy, vanilla, woody notes to
them as well with the stout.
And a lot of people are doing
bourbon barrel aged these days.
If you love bourbon
and you love beer,
it's just a perfect
marriage between the two,
if it's done right.
There's some really
wonderful Belgian Quads
if you're really into
deep stone-fruity,
boozy, foreign styles of beer.
There's something beautiful
about just a normal Kolsch.
A very simple German Kolsch
that is refreshing and light.
And so, try them all.
Follow your palate.
I mean that's really it.
Who am I to sit
up here-- I mean,
except that I was invited
to-- to say, try these beers.
Follow your palate.
Follow your passion.
Follow where your
taste buds move you.
Because again, it's subjective.
Whatever I say-- I could
say, oh this is a must
try before you die.
And you could drink it
and go, this is awful!
He doesn't know what the
hell he's talking about!
Personal palates are different.
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: So you were talking
about some of the reasons
why people say they
don't like beer.
JOHN HOLL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And one that
I hear in LA a lot
is it's too many carbs.
It's too heavy.
Blah, blah, blah.
Do you see anything in
the craft beer industry
trying to tackle that, or
approach that, or market that?
JOHN HOLL: So I'm
not in the best
of physical conditions
as a beer drinker.
So it's tough for me to talk
about the caloric intake.
But here's the thing.
A lot of people will cite
that beer is bad for you,
or worse for you than wine or
spirits and that kind of thing.
It's really not.
It's comparable to some
of those, sometimes.
But it's everything
in moderation.
Really.
If you're going to drink three
six packs a night, or three six
packs a week.
And then not work
out, and all that.
Well yeah.
It's going to be bad for you.
But I've been out
traveling where
I've seen people just kill
a bottle of wine themselves.
And that's not better for you.
It's not much [INAUDIBLE].
What we've seen
though is there's
a lot of the larger
beer companies that
market to a lower
calorie intake.
So ones that say, we
only have 65 calories.
Or we only have 100 calories,
and things like that.
65.
No, I wasn't trying
to like-- I'm
getting corrected in the back.
It's Miller 64!
I was trying to give
them a pass on this one.
I was trying to give them
a pass of just throwing out
an arbitrary number then
a watered-down beer.
But a Guinness, for example.
They had a big advertising
campaign a couple of years ago,
it has about 125 calories in it.
Right?
People would think
that it has a lot more.
Your normal beers are
somewhere in the 100 to 200
calorie range.
It's not that bad for you,
considering everything else
that we might eat
during the day.
It's just that perception
that beer makes you bloated,
or beer makes you fat,
or you get a beer belly.
Or all those manners
of things that wine
has done a very good
job, and spirits
have done a very good
job of sort of playing up
the sophistication
and the health aspect,
or the higher
aspect range of it.
So it's not necessarily
bad for you.
It's just everything
in moderation.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So my question was more
do you see something--
because I agree with
you, I love beer.
And I don't think
it's bad for you.
But there's that
perception out there,
whether you see something
in the marketing.
Is that something that's
trying to be attacked head-on.
Or if it's just conversations
like these where you say--
JOHN HOLL: It's not being
attacked head-on in the way
that I would like the
industry to attack it head-on.
I think that if brewers
started putting caloric intakes
on there, I think it
could help or hurt.
Because you're going
to get some beers that
are going to have
600 calories in them,
just given by the
nature of the sugar.
And they're not going to
want to put that on there.
And if one brewery makes a
beer that has 100 calories,
and the same brewery
makes one that has 600,
do you do a blanket or not?
And then you're going to get
accused of false advertising.
So I think it's a slippery
slope for a lot of them.
Every couple years that
"Eat This, Not That,"
"Drink This, Not That."
book comes back into vogue.
And invariably they show
up on the Today Show.
And it's have this
beer that's like water.
And not this barleywine
that has 600 calories.
You can't even
compare the two beers.
And it's like if I'm going
to drink this barleywine,
that means I'm only
going to have one.
And it means that
rather than drinking
six of those, which would
actually equal one of these.
And that's something
that we need to change.
But that's a question for
the individual brewers.
There's not an easy
answer, unfortunately,
for that at this point.
The other thing,
just perception-wise,
we were talking about
calories, one of the things
I wanted to point out
just really quickly.
As you look at the bottles
up there that we had today,
you'll see a lot of the famous
brown glass 12-ounce bottles.
But you also see the larger
22-ounce bottle of the IPA.
And then that really
cool-looking bottle
that we have with this blonde
that we're drinking right now.
And then there's also the can.
Which I always
love pouring cans,
because people think that
can is a lesser vessel.
It's really not.
It keeps out light.
It's easier to ship.
Keeping out light helps the
beer from getting that skunk
flavor, that oxidation
flavor as well.
It's lighter, so
it ships easier.
It's stackable.
You can take it camping.
You can take it to the poolside.
You can take it to the
shore without worrying
about broken glass.
So don't dismiss beers in cans.
I hope you all like
that flavorful beer.
You can crush it on your head
after you're done drinking it,
if you're really into it.
And if you've had a couple.
So yeah, don't dismiss
a beer in a can,
because I'm sure as
you were drinking it,
you didn't notice
any off flavors.
And you hopefully
enjoyed that beer.
And that came from a can.
So don't dismiss
it when you see it.
So thanks so much, guys.
This was really cool
for me to be here.
It's a company that I've
long admired from afar.
So to sit here with you guys and
be able to talk about the thing
that I love and the place
where you guys work and love
has been a really cool
experience for me.
And I hope that you enjoy
the book and your beer
and food-tasting journey.
I hope to come back and
do a beer dinner with you
guys at some point.
Cheers.
Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]